das hat diese woche in zwei züge geteilt
worden die eine ist in hochfilzen zum
schießen und wir sind eben zur wachau
ausbildung
wir haben heute die personen und
fahrzeugkontrolle geübt ist recht
interessant also wäre es bei der wache
gemacht wie immer die leute kontrolliert
auf was man auch nur spieler ganze
vorgang einfach ist
dies wird das her
länger als 30 minuten
die ladefläche helfen und alle kisten
aufmachen
[Musik]
jo hat haben wir als erstes den fall
geschossen das ist auch gut so einfach
was man sich so hübsch konzentrieren
dass das land hat
die erste branche noch immer kleiner
mieten
es ist wenn man oben drittel hätten auf
die entfernung den sand
genau das passt ins kino mieten drängen
[Musik]
jetzt ist er gehalten vor sehr schöne
ort vor 34 us-dollar fünfter nur dabei
ist weil es ziemlich groß das loch
[Musik]